thousands of former prisoners who
thought they would spend Christmas
behind bars are free thanks to the help
of the first step act President Trump
signed the legislation into law last
December the act increases the number of
good conduct time credits an inmate can
earn per year it also built on the Fair
Sentencing Act of 2010 signed by former
President Obama which reduced penalties
for crack cocaine offenses the US
Sentencing Commission says those changes
can help more than 140,000 people in
prison we spoke with two former inmates
who say they're still adjusting to their
newfound freedom before President Trump
signed the first step' Act into law did
you expect to spend the rest of your
life behind bars I did but I didn't
because I never gave up fighting 48
year-old Brian Johnson says it feels
good to be back in his old neighborhood
in Baltimore nearly 20 years ago Johnson
was convicted of money laundering and
drug distribution he was sentenced to
life in federal prison but when
President Trump signed off on the
first-step Act last December it meant
Johnson and thousands of others were
eligible for an earlier release or a
reduced sentence on July 9th Johnson
took his first step out of prison who
did you first lay eyes on when you got
out of prison the first person that I
sang was my oldest daughter how was she
31 you've missed most of her upbringing
20 years someone she pulled out it was
it was like an unbelievable feeling into
alcoho
he says he makes about $500 per week
working full-time for a delivery company
from prison life to this life I think
the assumption is oh you're free you
must be so excited it must be so great
it's great but will come with the
greatness is reality now you're back out
here cuz I mean you're gonna cost
already basically everything is free
food is free sleeping this fee in the
free world whether they say you've got
to pay for everything has that been the
biggest challenge for you actually no
technology has been amazing
for me right now I have a phone but I
couldn't tell you how to work everything
on the phone even harder than that
finding out he has a son since I've no
home I found out I have a son that's 26
years old and he is incarcerated in a
federal system for what 12 years for
carjacking does that hurt
yes they do because I feel like if I was
here that definitely man that recently
Johnson traveled to Washington DC with
the criminal justice reform group cut 50
which aims to reduce the prison
population by half he shared his story
with lawmakers fighting on behalf of
others who are still locked up there's a
lot we have left to do Holly Harris a
conservative and executive director of
the Justice Action Network pushed to
past the first step act if you had told
me 20 years ago that I would be working
with the ACLU and the n-double-a-cp I
would have called you crazy according to
the prison policy initiative the United
States has the highest incarceration
rate and the largest prison population
worldwide with about 2.3 million inmates
this is truly an American issue when
you're in prison you're locked in but
when you return to society you're locked
out you're locked out of a productive
life
clover Perez of Long Island New York
says that's exactly what she feared
after being released from federal prison
almost a year early
she served eight years for immigration
fraud my biggest concern was finding a
job I thought that I may not be
marketable and how was I going to catch
up she eventually found a job as an
office manager at a law firm her biggest
struggle she says coming to grips with
her oldest son's death he was shot and
killed about a year before she was
arrested when I come home I'll wait in
for Orangery to show up and he doesn't
show up it's a battle that I'm fighting
and I fight it every day and every day
as more inmates work to take their first
step out of
system the next step is making sure they
don't go back are you
a danger to society should people be
concerned about you people should not be
concerned about me I don't have nothing
to hide from the bottle intimidate no by
I go to work and I go home I know for a
fact that I'm a totally different person
this Danny's Johnson says prosecutors
are actually trying to appeal his
release and he's not alone a Reuters
investigation found dozens of cases
where the Justice Department tried to
keep offenders in prison most of those
attempts were unsuccessful so you know
the takeaway here really is it's not an
easy transition no I mean the first step
is obviously getting your freedom but
the next step is as we say at the end of
the piece really staying out of that
system right and you need the support in
order to do that when you realize as you
said that a hundred and forty thousand
people could be potentially affected by
this legislation that President Trump
has signed it will be and enduring
hallmark of president Trump's legacy so
absolutely and when you think about the
bipartisan right support they support
that exactly I mean that's why it was so
huge because even Holly Harris who you
heard in that piece she said that this
was something people told her this is
gonna take ten or fifteen years to pass
and here we are today and criminal
justice reform whether you're Republican
or Democrat people are coming together
and saying this is an issue we need to
do more about it first step you've got
to worry about that next step and your
jobs and skills need to be worked on
once they're not absolutely really
important reporting tarika thank you
very much for that
you